when he expected today good morning
Olivia well it's it's about 650 in the
morning here so you can see people
lining up the doors don't even open for
their 45 minutes and indeed the keynote
big event doesn't start for another few
hours but this google i/o conference is
interesting if only to point out the
differences between that other big
mobile operating system maker Apple and
Google because the things that are
expected to be announced here a new
version of their operating system a new
photo app that spun off of google plus
some iterations on their car software
and on their their plans for a potential
cardboard virtual reality device almost
all that stuff's already been announced
before indeed when you compare google to
Apple it's like comparing say an orange
to an apple they're different things
particularly when it comes to big
announcements because Google's not
really good at making big announcements
they release things iteratively they
talk about things in many stages they
talk about them all year so that there's
not a lot of drama built around an event
like this indeed the point for having
such a big event to announce a big
product all those prongs has already
been announced but there's still
business to be done it's the biggest
mobile operating system in the world so
something like 50 500 people or more are
gathered here in San Francisco to do
some business to learn a little maybe
hear a little about what might be coming
in the future Cory are you getting any
sense from the developers as to what the
next big thing for Google might be if
even if it doesn't come in a big splashy
product announcement apple style what's
going to be the next Android what's
going to be the next gmail what's going
to be the next search Google experiments
in so many places and comes up with a
lot of products that just don't get a
lot of traction and I think there's kind
of Google style is to throw a lot of
things against the wall and see what
sticks you know to be fair the news when
this conference is gonna happen for
quite a while because people are
literally just waking up and showing up
here doesn't really kick off for another
few hours so what what big news we might
get from this is how it will only know
from the carpet bombing of press
releases that starts to happen this
morning of sort of these minor
announcements but in terms of major big
movement you know they talked about
virtual reality this event last year
maybe they'll do more this year the the
Android suffice it starts to roll out
into cars over the season indeed young
guy just yesterday released their first
car with Android in the dashboard that's
the kind of thing where big developments
could happen in the future Cory how
about Android M if that's the new the
new lollipop I don't know where they get
these names where do they get these
names but what are you expecting out of
Android am I think there are needs are
major product changes in this new
release of Android software except for
promises of that it's going to work a
little more seamlessly one of the
interesting things about Android as it's
written on phones there are so many
different versions of Android that run
on so many different products that the
flagship Android a six-point om the new
android software it's just one version
of that there will be so many flavors
offered into so many phone makers that
what any individual user has to be quite
different from device to device I all
right there is going to be fingerprint
detection now standard in the am just
saying I'm looking forward to that
gorgeous all voices are will but there's
hard will require to yeah exactly that's
true I know you have a long day ahead of
you Cory will be out there covering the
Google conference for all of you to stay
tuned